konzentration steigern produktiver
werden schnell muskeln aufbauen
augenfarbe ändern
war da was als ich dieses thema
recherchiert habe habe ich wirklich
etwas an meinem verstand gezweifelt
normal wenn jemand dreiste lügen ins
netz stellt gibt es immer gegenwind in
form von kommentaren oder des leids aber
nicht hier
das verhältnis ist besser als ja besser
als bei meinen videos und die kommentare
lesen sich wie folgt wir hören die musik
jetzt schon zehn minuten und haben schon
fast blaue augen bei wem kribbelt auch
das auge
nach ungefähr 20 minuten haben meine
augen eine art grauen rand bekommen
deshalb habe ich mich dazu entschieden
das einfach mal auszuprobieren weil es
gibt für dieses für mich unerklärliche
phänomene nur drei mögliche antworten
erstens gekaufte klicks likes und
kommentare 2
tausende nutzer verbreiten kollektiv
lügen oder drittens das zeug
funktioniert dieses video wird von einem
schnittkurs unterstützt damit lernt ihr
in wenigen stunden alles was man für
einen schnitt von youtube urlaubs oder
musikvideos braucht da er aufgrund der
ausgangssperre ja alle zeit habt gibt es
aktuell 25 prozent rabatt auf alles es
handelt sich hierbei um unterschwellige
botschaften im prinzip sind sie
lediglich positive affirmationen aber in
einem frequenzbereich den erwachsenen
menschen nicht bewusst wahrnehmen können
sondern angeblich nur unterbewusst die
botschaften sollen dadurch an unseren
kritischen verstand vorbei deutlich
effektiver direkt in unser
unterbewusstsein gelangen das reguläre
positive affirmationen für manche sachen
sehr wichtig sein können wahrscheinlich
gar nicht in frage aber ob unser
unterbewusstsein wirklich diese
frequenzen waren und ob man dadurch
seine augenfarbe körpergröße oder
haarfarbe physikalisch verändern kann
wage ich eigentlich schon zu bezweifeln
aber wieso hat das dann nur positives
feedback ich meine kommentare kamen
löschen aber deswegen nicht
ich probiere es jetzt mal
ok also man braucht auch für kopfhörer
den 20.000 hertz abspielen können damit
diese ganzen unterschwelligen
botschaften auch wirklich zur geltung
kommen meine köln 40.000 herz also daran
sollte schon mal nicht an ich werde dir
audiospuren später auch mal mit einer
speziellen software überprüfen ob das
auch wirklich so hochfrequente
botschafterin sind könnte ja auch
einfach sein als die drei stunden musik
in dauerschleife hochladen und das war's
okay ich habe mal rein
ganz ehrlich wir werden es herausfinden
aber ich glaube nicht daran dass meine
augen blau werden ich möchte dies
einzudämmen ist aber auch wahr etwas
testen bei dem zumindest herkömmliche
affirmation meiner meinung nach wirksam
sein können und zwar bei der änderung
der eigenen einstellung hier konkret mit
der steigerung pro disziplin und
willenskraft also ich werde zeuge
wirklich rund um die uhr beim arbeiten
aufräumen in der pause ich habe die
kopfhörer hier sogar beim schlafen auf
aber ich werde mich auf zwei sammlungen
als beschränken weil viele experten
sagen dass man nicht zu viel auf einmal
machen soll
da sich diese botschaften sonst
versprechen können aber das angebot ist
ja wirklich interessant haare natürlich
schwarz färben für immer jung bleiben
alte probleme bewältigen natürliche
penisvergrößerung du hast den
allergrößten
ich lass das mal so stehen alle deine
mitmenschen lieben einen wunderschönen
langen und großen also das ist echt mega
skurril
ich frage mich einfach wer sich sowas
anschaut um das herauszufinden habe ich
aus mehreren videos tausende kommentare
verarbeitet und anhand der name
rückschlüsse auf das geschlecht gezogen
dort wo es eindeutig war mit hilfe eines
programms habe ich dann hunderte
kommentare mit altersangaben
herausgekommen ich weiß das ist aus
verschiedensten gründen nicht 100
prozent genau aber ich denke um einen
groben einblick zu bekommen genügt ist
die kommentatoren sind 72,5 prozent
weiblich zu 27,5 prozent männlich und
14,8 jahre alt misst beim durchforsten
der kommentare jedoch aufgefallen dass
es keine einzige richtig kritische
stimme gibt und kritische stimmen gibt
es eigentlich immer selbst bei dingen
die erwiesenermaßen funktionieren und
das finde ich schon relativ verdächtig
um ehrlich zu sein ich schreibe jetzt
einfach mal 2 3 kommentare die ein
bisschen kritischer sind irgend
herauszufinden ob der kanal besitzer
nicht vielleicht einfach die kommentare
intensiviert
[Musik]
ich bin mal gespannt was jetzt passiert
und die tage ziehen vorbei und ich höre
täglich mehrere stunden talent zu
bleiben ist bis dann immer noch grün
mittlerweile sind meine kritischen
kommentare auch verschwunden das heißt
negative meinungen werden einfach
zensiert und die heitere fitter blase
aufrechtzuerhalten mich interessiert
jetzt mal wie die sensible - die
angeblich so hoch qualitativ sind unter
der haube aussehen in der zwischenzeit
sage ich mal die audiospuren durch ein
spezielles audio programm um die
spektral frequenzen anzeigen zu können
damit wir mal sehen ob da überhaupt
diese versteckten botschaften drin sind
okay augenfarbe ändert was nein also als
ob die so dreist sind immer in gold da
ist einfach nichts ich habe 20.000 hertz
darum wurde mal die versteckten
botschaften seien sollten ja dann auf
das hatte ich mal am anfang des
experiments machen sollen weil
eigentlich sollte das nicht wieso
aussehen also nehme ich da ganz oben so
ein paar dinger die man halt nicht hört
aber hier ist nichts die sich immer
wiederholenden rhythmen und angeblich
unterschwelligen botschaften zeigen bei
mir also wer hätte es gedacht keinen
effekt und selbst wenn sich die video
hersteller die mühe gemacht hätten echte
sabres hochzuladen auf der suche nach
wissenschaftlichen beweisen finde ich
fast nur artikel von sulander websites
selbst es wird sich oft auf ein sehr
bekanntes experiment aus den 1950 er
jahren gestützt indem man in kinofilmen
für millisekunden den text trinkt kann
geblendet hat welcher zwar für das
bewusstsein zu kurz war aber wohl
unterbewusst dafür gesorgt hat erst die
verkaufszahlen in die höhe schossen
das einzige problem dabei ist dass das
nicht passiert ist ein gerücht weiterhin
beruft man sich oft auf irgendwelche
angemeldeten patente streut anekdoten
dazwischen wie toll das ganze dorf sei
und erwähnt mal eine alte studie die
sich mit etwas augenscheinlich ähnlichem
beschäftigt aber in wirklichkeit ein
ganz anderes thema ist und so finde ich
nach langer recherche wieder ein beweis
noch eine schlüssige studie die vermuten
lässt dass das unterbewusstsein etwas
mit diesen unhörbaren hochfrequenten
affirmationen anfangen kann
ich bin ja selbst entfernt davon mit
seinem bewusstsein zu experimentieren
zum beispiel in form von meditation oder
luziden träumen ich habe auch nichts
dagegen wenn leute dinge praktizieren
die ich für unmöglich oder verrückt
heute soll doch jeder machen was er will
wenn sie unglücklich macht aber nun aber
ein kanal gezielt die unsicherheiten von
meist jungen und leicht beeinflussbaren
menschen ausnutzt inhaltlich genau dahin
geht wo viele ängste haben trauer
verspüren oder sogar gemobbt wird und
ihnen eine einfache fantastische lösung
präsentiert die oft physikalisch gar
nicht funktionieren kann nur um sie dann
auf seine website zu locken
und wenn sich dieser kanal dann noch
nicht mal die mühe machten die von ihm
so hoch angepriesenen frequenzen
überhaupt in die videos einzubauen
als er eh keiner merkt dann ist es schon
echthaar täglich ich finde es echt
traurig dass es so viele menschen gibt
die das gefühl haben auf solche lösungen
zurückgreifen zu müssen
die themen die solche kanäle werden
lassen sich eigentlich in drei
kategorien aufteilen
erstens es ist einerseits unmöglich und
andererseits ist es auch egal also wenn
ihr probleme mit eurer augenfarbe oder
körpergröße hat oder sonst was dann ist
es der einzige gesunde trägt sich selbst
davon zu überzeugen dass er gut seid so
wie ihr seid und euch auf das zu
konzentrieren was sind eure kontrolle
liebt dann gibt es noch die kategorie
realitätsfremd ich weiß ihr sucht nach
magie und zauber im leben und das kann
ich auch verstehen das ist auch nicht
schlimm ist und auch nichts verrücktes
aber das brauchen einen meiner meinung
nach kein hellseher oder telepathie weil
die welt und das universum so wie es ist
die bringt schon genug maki und
unentdecktes für 1000 menschenleben mit
wenn man danach aus verhalten dann gibt
es noch die kategorie der dinge die man
wirklich machen kann weil man sich
reinhängt natürlich kann man sich nicht
einfach mit youtube video anschauen und
ist dann ein muskulöser aber man kann
sich ein halbes jahr lang im
fitnessstudio abdrehen und essen wie ein
freak obwohl man keinen bock hat und
stehen am ende da wie ein champ der sich
das auch verdient hat und das gilt
natürlich nicht nur die muskeln sondern
auch für andere dem leben auf die man
selber einfluss hat wenn ihr jetzt lust
hat das schneiden so lernen kann ich
euch meinen schnittkurs empfehlen bei
dem man alles in kürzester zeit lernt
was man für youtube-videos musikvideos
aber auch für urlaubsvideos braucht der
link das wirkt ist in dem video
beschreibung und da er gerade alle zu
hause setzt in ausgangssperre gibt es 25
prozent rabatt auf alles von meiner
kunst plattform link in der video
beschreibung letzte woche habe ich mit
aktien gehandelt bzw cfd-trading
betrieben und versucht aus 1000 euro
möglichst viel zu machen wenn ihr das
sehen möchte klickt hier und wenn ihr
mich abonnieren möchte dann klickt hier
[Musik]